tous cas montagneux avec kilométrage en
augmentation grâce à la commission
technique
tout cela c'est pour préparer l'avenir
de notre supply puisque après il ya le
tour de guadeloupe via le tour de guyane
ya le championnat de la caraïbe il ya le
championnat de france d'auto nerfs après
le tout la saison n'est pas finie nous
continuons mouvement beaucoup d'action
pour toujours une seule mission le
progrès du cyclisme martiniquais le
niveau d éviter le niveau des invités un
cran plus que l'an dernier
alors cette fâcheuse réflexion canton
martinique et gagnent 10 ha ouais les
invités n'étaient pas de taille
l'anssi j'ai mis l'accent sur les
invités on demande de certains les
invités ils auront
un coin de plus je pense que ça nous
permettra de courir après pour permettre
que le cyclisme je travaillais évolué et
que nous puissions avoir un beau
spectacle
le tout par du robert cette année le
tout par un nouveau maire remercie à la
ville du robert du gaubert et puis nous
resterons dans une animation deux
mouvements toute la matinée alors tout
un programme est mis en place pour le
coup d'envoi du tour robert la cérémonie
d'ouverture
dès le matin 8h30 du matin la signature
la présentation des commissaires la
présentation de la caravane publicitaire
la présentation de le signaleur à pied à
moto gendarmerie en fait tout ce qui
concerne la bulle sportif la bulle de
sécurité
nous allons les présenter présenter un
an dernier la caravane de nos cyclistes
le peloton de cyclistes et puis des
groupes à pied vous les accompagnez au
départ nous partirons fait pour faire le
paon coup alors que la ville de robert
restera en fait avec un podium
une belle animation pour garder le
public en marche